[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsables tras más
de 80 días de guerra en ucrania rusia
logró finalmente hacerse con el control
del puerto de mariupol y las tropas
ucranianas aseguraron haber terminado su
misión de combate en la serie de asos
tal y los esfuerzos se concentran ahora
en la evacuación de los últimos
combatientes en el norte del país tras
perder control en la región de jarquín
las tropas rusas se han concentrado en
el donbass y los combates se enfocan en
severodonezk a la ciudad más importante
de la provincia de lugansk a nuestros
enviados especiales catalina gómez ángel
y mikel konaté lograron llegar hasta
esta ciudad junto con una pareja de
voluntarios que distribuye ayuda y esto
fue lo que encontrará
la neisseria vienen a destruir ayuda
humanitaria a personas que han decidido
quedarse
e intentar evacuar a quienes quieren
irse
la mayoría son mayores pensionados y sin
medios para oír como este grupo que vive
en un centro cultural del issys antes
cada rincón se ha convertido en una casa
provisional esta abuela vive en el
sótano junto con algunos familiares
ella dice que que hacen su vida desde
hace 80 días cocinan rezan limpian
la pareja tiene prisa les preocupa que
sólo tienen un par de horas antes de que
se recrudezcan los ataques en la
carretera de acceso
visitante es en lo alto de la montaña y
severo dos nietos en la parte baja no
podemos ver de esta aquí esa dirección
es sheraton yesca
en severo dones las calles están
abandonadas las fuerzas rusas la cedhj
en la lucha por controlarla es crucial
en la lucha por la región del donbass
muchos no tienen otra opción que
sobrevivir de la ayuda que les llega y
necesitamos que esta guerra se acabe tan
pronto como sea posible si nos pueden
ayudar con algo no tenemos carne papas
cebollas zanahorias
mirad yo en este colegio junto con 16
personas incluido una pequeña
desde hace semanas no tienen
electricidad agua en internet
ellos atacan en esta dirección y los
otros devuelven usted puede ver que la
escuela tiene heridas necesitamos
cocinar afuera no tenemos otra opción
tenemos que comer tú
esta gente está traumatizada todavía se
puede hablar con algunos de ellos pero
más de la mitad no entienden qué pasa
esto sucede porque viven en sótanos y
rodeados por el miedo castellanas en sus
trajes
estamos en la parte final de
severodonezk y nos dicen que aquí las
tropas rusas están a 1.7 kilómetros
hacia esta dirección y 4 hacia esta
dirección ayer hubo una gran batalla y
aquí todos dicen que tienen bastante
miedo
cada día que pasa la vida es más difícil
el edificio a ludmila ha sido atacado
como muchos ella asegura que al menos el
40 por ciento de los residentes no se
han ido la mayoría son jubilados no han
hecho mire esto no hay nada es agua
vamos a tomar té y nada más que podemos
hacer
selenski putin necesitan reunirse y
negociar porque la gente se siente
abandonada completamente tenemos mucha
gente mayor
mira quisiera irse si la situación se
complica aún más pero posiblemente ya es
demasiado tarde de sergei también que no
habrá otra oportunidad de regresar las
fuerzas rusas están cada vez más cerca y
la batalla se recrudece
las llanuras del estadio ucrania son en
estos días escenario de la guerra más
cruenta la contraofensiva ucraniana ha
mandado a las tropas rusas más allá del
río don es que nuestras enviadas
especiales en el terreno irene sabio y
leticia álvarez se han desplazado hasta
la primera línea para comprobar el
avance ucraniano
los puentes de acceso están destrozados
para impedir el paso de las tropas rusas
en plena ofensiva el ejército ucraniano
nos autoriza a llegar hasta el frente
sur la guerra se difumina entre pueblos
retomados y fronteras invisibles la
contraofensiva se ve cerca
y el amor
este pueblo está dividido en dos al otro
lado del río donde se posicionan las
tropas rusas oled es comandante segundo
del ejército ucraniano desde su posición
controla el movimiento de los soldados
rusos
de esta primera línea es de la
destrucción de morteros recibimos
aviación artillería pero lo que más
recibimos son morteros luchamos contra
todo el perfil y de nuevo de todos
nuestros jóvenes del sur piccini git
está a tan sólo un kilómetro del frente
y en esta ciudad ahora mismo ya lo
pueden ver hay tranquilidad pero es lo
más terrorífico de esta guerra
convencional que un ataque puede pasar
en cualquier momento
los niños juegan en el parque parece que
la guerra da un respiro pero valentina
no puede controlar el dolor que está
viviendo y nos preocupamos por todas las
personas ahora estamos todos juntos
unidos vamos todos para uno y uno para
todos y creo en los pueblos retomados
por el ejército ucraniano la imagen es
muy distinta en rosca ya lo soba todos
son ruinas y restos que las tropas rusas
dejaron en su vida incluso estas zonas
recuperadas continúan siendo inestables
y es que la primera línea en esta guerra
en ucrania se difumina entre sus
carreteras estamos en una de las zonas
recuperadas en la zona de harnik y en
estos momentos seguimos escuchando el
sonido de la artillería muy cercana
en las puertas de los vecinos de las
zonas ocupadas se puede leer la palabra
es motril casa inspeccionada en ruso son
los restos de la invasión en la primera
línea del frente en ucrania
la invasión rusa a ucrania ha generado
una grave crisis energética mundial pero
también otra de aún mayor gravedad ya la
que no se le ha prestado el mismo tipo
de atención hablamos de la crisis
alimentaria rusia y ucrania producen el
30 por ciento de las exportaciones
globales de trigo y se estima que unos
26 países dependen de estas dos naciones
para la mitad de los granos que consumen
la guerra deja a los países en
desarrollo en vilo debido a que las
reservas de alimentos que produce
ucrania se mantienen bloqueadas en los
puertos debido a la presencia rusa se
estima que a pesar de su condición de
productores un tercio de la población
ucraniana necesita comida nuestras
enviadas especiales irene savio y
leticia álvarez nos cuentan más
a las doce del mediodía de un día normal
y angélica estarían trabajando como
empleadas de una tienda de jarquín pero
ahora han perdido su trabajo no tienen
suficiente comida y los constantes
cortes de electricidad
también complican el cocinar
teníamos trabajo y dinero vivíamos como
todos pero con la guerra esto es lo que
ha pasado de casi todo
angélica que como dirá es vecina del
barrio de sal y cova explica que el
acceso a las ayudas no es fácil bueno
sharm hemos violado el toque de queda
desplazándonos a las 4 de la mañana para
registrarnos en las listas pero esto no
ha sido ninguna garantía solo pocas
veces hemos conseguido algo algún trozo
de pepino que cebolla y pan y puedo
justo pues botón o ucrania era el
granero de europa
solía abastecer de trigo al mundo pero
ahora tiene dificultades para alimentar
a toda su población muchos centros de
ayuda están colapsadas según el programa
mundial de alimentos más de 10 millones
de personas necesitan comida en este
momento en ucrania pero sólo tres
misiones la están recibiendo el
resultado es este desesperación de hecho
organizaciones como el programa mundial
de alimentos están en el terreno pero el
alargamiento de la guerra el aumento de
los precios y la escasez de gasolina
siguen operando la situación y más
ciudades necesitan ayuda como también
ocurre en sabor y yo temo que la
situación empeorará más gente necesitará
ayuda nosotros estamos intentando hacer
lo mejor como humanitarios para
ayudarles porque esto está sobrepasando
a las administraciones locales la
sociedad civil las ong y el esfuerzo de
los voluntarios para ayudar al pueblo
ucraniano en medio de esta incertidumbre
la población que no dejó el país lucha
por su propia supervivencia
de acuerdo con la oficina de la alta
comisionada para los derechos humanos de
naciones unidas desde el inicio de la
guerra más de 3600 civiles han muerto y
unos 3.900 han resultado heridos la gran
mayoría de estas víctimas se cuentan
como consecuencia de las arremetidas
contra objetivos civiles ya sea con
misiles o artillería por parte de las
fuerzas rusas dichos ataques todavía se
están documentando e investigando
nuestras enviadas especiales en el
terreno recorrieron algunos de los
barrios más afectados de la ciudad de
jarquín
olga fue testigo de cómo su barrio de
mosca le quedó arrasado
fue un proyectil y después de una bomba
que lanzaron lo destruyó todo aquí las
casas la escuela los cristales rotos los
muros rotos surtan mi cabaña moda
rápidamente culpa pausa desde que empezó
la invasión rusa en ucrania los
objetivos civiles han sido fuertemente
bombardeados y constantemente
bombardeados sobre todo en ciudades como
kiev mariupol o harkis donde nos
encontramos esta escuela fue bombardeada
la segunda semana del conflicto y ya lo
pueden ver hasta el autobús de
transporte de los menores está
destrozado no solo hay escuelas atacadas
también hospitales
y barrios enteros de viviendas el barrio
dormitorio the horizon fue uno de los
primeros objetivos de las tropas rusas
en kharkiv mijael lleva viviendo en el
sótano del edificio desde hace dos meses
7 aplaudo esta leche creada en broma
mitch exquisitas quería tanto tristes
croydon dos proyectiles golpearon en
este edificio uno cayó en la entrada y
el otro dañó el décimo sexto piso todo
está destruido las comunicaciones
destruidas los ascensores cayeron nadie
murió aquí pero si en el edificio de al
lado donde dictó ni para tomm con un
poquito de boyle pedro ramis ha habido
repetidos ataques contra la población
civil en este barrio lo podemos ver
edificios de civiles en una zona
residencial de jarque han sido atacados
en los primeros días de este conflicto
vladimir putin ha justificado esta
invasión como un intento de parar la
otan y asegura que sus objetivos son
militares y estratégicos pero sobre el
terreno son los civiles los que están
sufriendo las consecuencias de esta
guerra
casi tres meses después del inicio de la
guerra en ucrania luego que millones de
personas hayan sido desplazadas y que
varias ciudades hayan sido destruidas la
vida comienza a reanudarse lentamente
izquierda la capital el siguiente es un
informe del enviado especial de nuestras
cadenas hermanas gulliver crack
hace apenas unos días la mayoría de
estos bancos estaban vacíos
pero una semana después del 9 de mayo la
vida en las calles vuelve a kiev y el
ambiente en la capital ucraniana es un
poco más tranquilo
en las carreteras los bloqueos
antitanques se han movido a las aceras
pero están listos para desplegarse
rápidamente si la situación se deteriora
por ahora los cafés están abiertos y
aunque las sirenas antiaéreas suenan de
vez en cuando la mayoría de la gente las
ignora
en amor nunca más volverá a la
normalidad para nosotros pero tratamos
de vivir la situación en la que estamos
ahora y empezar a hacer una vida normal
lo haremos cada día mejor
aunque el transporte público y la
mayoría de las tiendas están en
funcionamiento todavía hay sacos de
arena frente a las estaciones de metro
el robot continua
volver a la vida normal es un proceso
que continuará pero está mucho más
tranquilo ahora que hace unas semanas la
ciudad tiene una vida normal como los
grandes
ucrania ganó la batalla por kiev pero no
se puede escapar al hecho de que es la
capital de un país en guerra el futuro
es difícil de predecir y casi todos en
la ciudad conocen a alguien que está en
primera línea
muchas gracias por seguir un nuevo
episodio de corresponsales nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom